Uh yeah. Yeah. Thank you. Um I'm Brooks.
I do work at Dropbox as a um
infrastructure cloud security engineer.
But this presentation is more about the
agents I've been building um on my own,
the ones I run every day. Um kind of the
things I've been building and breaking
and uh the issues I've run into and
lessons learned and uh fun things like
that. So everything I'm going to
reference here is uh open source on my
GitHub. Um it's not really the open
source that you can just download and
run. It's open source like you can look
at the code and try to figure out how to
do it. But it does all run for me. So
good luck if you want to go try.
So this is uh I did update all these
numbers last night and I think it's
already out of date again. Um but I have
like 19 different agents. Um agent is
kind of a catchall here. There's, I
think, 13ish interactive ones, a few
other that are more like service agents,
kind of cron jobs that call either cloud
code or a different agent. Um, 73
different MCP tools uh just on a local
stddio um MCP server. So, that that has
things like um email that I've been
playing around with a little bit. um
creating files, reading from the file
system
uh different
tools around uh the OS that I want to
give them access to and just anytime I
want to create another tool, put it in
there and then I uh
I'll get into the capability system in a
little bit. But then I try to scope it
down so every agent doesn't have to see
every um MCP tool. I mean that that's uh
just pretty much good security and also
good for the functionality so we're not
uh polluting the context.
Um I also created several different ways
to start these agents. I typically do
use CLI tools for a lot of this stuff
but I have thrown in like a web UI um
voice kind of wrapper both in the web UI
and kind of a standalone app and um also
have it connected just to my personal
Slack so I can add a specific agent. it
kind of goes through a filtering system,
sends it to the right place and uh I get
a response.
Uh so through all this um I I do also
interact with a couple remote MCP
servers that are also permissioned
different ways, mainly the personal ones
I've been building for myself and uh
GitHub, but I'll get into some of that
permissioning uh in a little bit. And
then also just uh some of the security
controls I've been putting in place
capabilities bounding like I mentioned
making sure there's um each MCP tool has
a permission scope so read write admin
etc. Make sure memory is isolated and um
observability and then also yeah the the
max iterations per turn ended up being
very helpful. I've optimized it down to
probably about three or four iterations
that I'm normally hitting now, but
that's a good way to kind of make sure
you don't end up spending too much.
Uh so I can actually go through and show
some of the um workflows that I do do
with it. So right now I automate a lot
of uh coding processes. So I have kind
of a custom task management system here
where I just pretty much have a cron job
that's a cloud-p
command that goes through and it will
start getting
uh things fixed or optimized for me. So
you can see um this is just kind of a
report from it. You can see kind of the
things it does.
But then um you might ask what happens
if we run out of tasks. If it does that
then it runs I have a few code review um
sub aents. So like it'll do security
auditing, testing, that's like test
coverage, code quality, documentation,
etc. And then it will uh make more tasks
for those. So pretty much I have a a
kind of a self-sustaining code
optimization ecosystem that will keep
running until it maxes out my credit
card and Claude uh cuts me off.
And then um through this though I am
getting you know into the place where
there's a lot less human in the loop for
a lot of this which is definitely a
scary place to be. Uh I I have been
trying to put together like weekly PR
reviews. So I'll go through and um go
through all the reviews or go through
all the PRs. uh try to analyze what
might be good, what might be bad, what
process I should ina be put in place and
then um each PR review or each PR
already has like CI tests. I have two
cloud review agents that go through and
I've set it up so that way the automated
tasks um they have to keep iterating
until the cloud review bots pretty much
say that it's good to go. So try to have
some safe checks or safety checks to
make sure LLM isn't uh just giving me
complete garbage. And so far it has been
working fairly well. Definitely um some
things that I'd like to optimize a bit
more, but definitely uh not a bad place
to be.
So yeah, as I mentioned, I have a
capabilities bounding and permission
control system set up. So each agent has
um both uh both allowed tools that it's
allowed to have and also the permissions
um for those tools that it can use. So
the task manager agent is definitely
kind of my daily driver that goes
through and helps me automatically
complete tasks, break things down, um
reschedules when I haven't updated tasks
in a while.
So that has uh you know the permissions
to go search for stuff, message me in
Slack, email me, memory obviously. Then
I have some things like security
researcher readon. It's just kind of I
ask it questions about you know blog
posts or um different things and it goes
through kind of the rag I've been
setting up the web answers things there.
And then I do have just a chatbot that
has everything. That's kind of my um
test. Um, but of of course I want to set
up this up to be secure by default as I
add more tools to the everexpanding MCP
server. So definitely need to make sure
that uh tools are locked down by
default. You know, you have to go
specifically add tools or add
permissions. Everything is going to be
locked down to admin otherwise. And I
have a quick kind of demo on how that
works.
There we go.
Um, so it's just going to go through
here's kind of how I can run the chatbot
agent. Um, give it specific permissions.
So here read send. Uh, so here it has no
write privileges to memory and we're
asking it to try to save memories and
kind of see the denial. the agent's
aware that okay, you know, it has a a um
verbose enough error message that it
knows what's going on. It can tell me,
you know, what I might be doing wrong,
what I can fix. Um and then if you do,
you know, not restrict it because this
is the chatbot that has all the
permissions or all the MCP tools, then
memory works fine, you kind of see how
I've uh been storing the memory, which
I'll I'll go into a little bit later as
well. And um yeah, the the Wi-Fi here is
definitely leaves a little bit to be
desired. Just a little slow, but here it
just shows key value. Sometimes it'll
print out the whole JSON, which is nice.
And then um that will get cleaned up.
So, one thing uh I'm also been working
on which is kind of a preview of
mistakes I'm definitely going to make is
this uh MCP kind of relay or it's a MCP
server that's more or less a chat room
for my um for my LLMs. So I originally
created it just to kind of help debug
server client communic or servant
clients uh interactions because got
really tired of uh copying and pasting
between cloud code on the server cloud
code on the client. So here we have the
MC P or the plot is trying to debug kind
of a local uh clients
uh let's see we can have the server
session uh say like you know here's the
source code so the client is trying to
get debugged and then then they'll start
uh chatting back and forth and sending
messages to each other so that way they
can uh debug it even though all the
server code might not be accessible to
the client. So it's been yeah super
helpful in uh making client server
connections work better especially as a
lot of this is uh internet MCP traffic
now but of course this is uh not the
most secure setup right now it is
running on my home lab where only I uh
interact with it but it's definitely not
production ready we're injecting context
from one LM to another uh capabilities
are not being scoped down but that
that's other things I'm working on
there.
And with that, I've also just given
myself a web interface so you can kind
of see the kind of discussions between
them. Uh right now, this is all just in
memory on the server. Like right when
this is over, I'm going to start putting
a Reddus back end in for it as well and
uh continue on there. But then that also
leads to the question uh what if I want
to debug something on a server that
doesn't have like clog code or LLM on
it. So I have also put together a remote
agent
uh
that can run on like say one of my
Proxmox LXC containers that have half a
gig of RAM. So you can run it. Uh right
now I just set it up with OOTH because
that's the authentication I use for all
agents
because it's set up and it works.
And then it will also just go to a chat
room window and pull and wait for
commands. So this is pretty much uh for
me it's a good debugging tool. Other
people might see it as a um implant.
It it again very insecure. Don't use
this right now at least. But one one of
my goals is to see how I can transfer
capabilities from the agent to Linux
permissions or do some sort of uh
permissions bounding put it up in like a
restricted user and uh go from there.
And similarly you can see like the uh
LLM is debugging. at sending commands.
You can see what's getting sent here.
And uh we're also keeping these logs on
the um MCP relay on the
uh soon to be Reddus server.
Let's see a wrong one. Yes. So you can
see the commands and everything being
sent there.
So just some videos in case that didn't
work, but thankfully it did. So yeah,
one of the issues I ran out ran into
with memory is that um I knew obviously
for different like clients or different
users, you want to isolate memory. But
for when I was just creating agents for
myself, I was like, you know, just just
create a postcrest table, throw memories
in there and uh it should work. Uh which
it does work. They do remember stuff.
But I ran into a lot of kind of uh
annoying functionality issues. Like uh
the one that kind of really led to me
fixing it was this first one where I
asked my task manager to break down
tasks for me and it would take um I also
threw together a business agent that was
just like look through my GitHub see how
I can make money and I was like telling
that to optimize try to get $1,000 a
month see what you can do. So then every
time I'd ask my task manager to break
stuff down it would mention that it's
optimizing for this $1,000 month goal
which was very frustrating to me because
that was kind of just aside kind of for
fun. let's see what happens thing. And
after a bunch of these leakages between
different uh agents and you know other
agents memories, it did really lead me
to kind of trying to set up a better
memory isolation system
so that way each agent could have its
own identity and that identity would be
mapped to a kind of memory name space.
Uh so currently identity is only pretty
much set up by the like each um agent is
just a Python subclass of my agent
framework uh agent class. So that they
take that class name and then that when
they uh set up their local MCP server
that class name gets sent to the MCP
server and is uh just translated into
the name space here. So that way LLMs
have no control over what their
namespace key is. They can't you know
try to decide there's somebody else get
memories. So that is kind of the
identity setup I have. It's definitely
pretty simple and probably needs
expanding fairly soon, but it has been
working pretty well um off the bat.
So yeah, I have a quick uh demo for that
as well.
Um
but so pretty much we'll show you how
you can like save a memory. So here we
have I just have a kind of a test memory
script which we'll save. Oh yeah, here's
the kind of memory format um right here.
So you see see there's a key, we have a
value, you can categorize it, put
importance, etc.
And um go through and see if it can find
its own memory and then we'll see that
another agent cannot find this memory.
But like another issue I ran into at the
beginning was I was injecting all the
memories which um can be helpful but you
start filling up your context really
fast and a lot of times agents don't
need to know everything that they've
remembered. So I did go through and set
it up so that way only the important
memories I think like importance eight
or above uh gets uh auto injected. They
also have search memory functions so
they can go and search for anything
specific. So you can see like it can
find it. You have some you know agentic
response it wants to throw emojis in
there. Um, and then the security agent
will go look for it and it won't
shouldn't find anything. And actually,
it's getting caught by my uh LM firewall
there, which is also another issue that
I'll I'll talk about in just a second.
So, as you can see there, the memory
called got uh blocked, which was not
what I intended, and it's still, you
know, prompt injection detection, not
plug-and-play, uh, still needs more
tuning. And uh it was just kind of I
wanted to put in some prompt scanning
see you know add some security to this
as I went. But uh like the most annoying
thing here is I'd have uh like this last
one include a server time field in every
API response. That was an actual task I
wanted to do. So I was like go create
this task for me so I remember to do it.
And then like two weeks later I was
checking through the LM firewall logs
and I saw that was blocked along with
like a couple dozen other tasks. So then
all of a sudden I'm missing out on this
stuff. So out of the box configuration
way too aggressive. Um had to go tune
that down and still trying to figure out
what kind of custom customizations I
want. Like obviously security research
queries are going to have more stuff. So
that needs to be very insensitive if
it's there at all and then kind of
figure out where the accepted risk
tolerance is for each um setting there.
Another thing that I at least think is
pretty cool is I have a kind of a
context aware trimming uh thing set up.
This is mainly for log analysis because
the um problem it solves is if I have an
LLM that is going through say security
logs in this example, it's contact is
going to get filled up. It's going to uh
trim the context, start throwing stuff
away, but I don't want uh like an
attacker to be able to just send an
attack every 200,000 tokens and then I
only see, you know, one at a time. So,
I've set up a way so I can uh tag uh
different messages as different things.
So that way uh I can say this is a
security like in this case the SSRF
server side request forgery was blocked
permission to deny those are important
security events let's make sure whenever
the context is trimmed we keep these
around and uh use use them for our
security analysis there. So this is
definitely still not, you know, 100%
perfect. Um, and as the logs increase,
contacts get longer, I'm running these
agents for longer times, uh, the context
can still fill up. So it's just figuring
out, uh, how to adjust that as we go is
another fun challenge. So I can show
kind of yeah how that works
because pretty much what happens is just
with the oh
with the um
the logs that come back they get tagged
with different security events. So you
can see we have like uh some metadata
set for as like server side request
forgery blocked or permission denied. Um
and then I'll go trim the messages and
you know we make sure we keep the the
security one relevant ones there.
And there's demo reporting. So of course
uh observability is key. It's um very
hard to do or very hard to do thoroughly
enough. But like right when I started up
uh cost tracking I did see I was wasting
tons of tokens on both uh injecting all
the memories all at once which they
didn't need and was actually um hurting
functionality as well. Um, I had like
the coding agents always try to run all
the review agents all the time because
it uh when I was coding that that's what
the LM thought would be helpful which
was also like every time you run those
five uh review agents it's like 250k
tokens. So I was just running that way
more often than I needed to. Right now I
have langfuse traces um that are super
helpful to kind of see which agents are
doing what. I've accidentally uh used
opus where I meant to use sonnet in
several places and langfuse helps kind
of debug where that is. Graphana
dashboards for cost daily breakdown um
making sure that you do have a security
audit trail and because a lot of this a
lot of uh my auto agent automations are
running like 24/7 or uh at least cron
jobs every hour or two. And uh I do want
to know like if I wake up and I have an
extra $100 bill, why did that happen?
how can I trace that down? So, yeah, a
lot of uh lessons learned. So,
thankfully being a security
practitioner, I did uh put a lot of
security stuff in place for early on
like permission systems, tool allow
lists. That was kind of a I know this is
important. Let's go see what I can do
with it. Um
and that's like a great example of how
improved security also improves actual
functionality. Um because with like 73
MCP tools, if we're injecting that into
every LLM, they're going to have so much
both context is wasted and they're going
to have so much extra information that's
just not going to be helpful for
whatever their mission is. And then
also, yeah, just making sure agents are
scoped down as much as possible. Uh so
that way they do have kind of distinct
things they're trying to do. You can
limit, you know, MCP tools a bit more.
you can kind of limit all the additional
context that might lead them different
directions and kind of keep them focused
just like you'd want to keep a human
focused and uh yeah just natural chest
brown bounties contextware trimming etc.
And then um a lot of things I should
have done differently. Uh cost tracking,
you know, tune some of the stuff before
I'm deploying. Since it is just my home
lab, I just push stuff out. Uh if I
break it, then I go fix it. And then
also just yeah, delegation chains is
something I still need to work on. Uh
identity type stuff. I'm I'm sure like
the SANS talk later will will help with
that, but trying to go figure out the
best way to do that and pass the same
identity everywhere we can. Um so that's
pretty much what I have. Feel free to
reach out to me, LinkedIn, uh send me an
email. I have a whatever those
PowerPoint cards were called. Uh but
yeah, and uh there's the code's all on
GitHub if you want to just go look at
it.
I will definitely look at your code. Um
are you looking for sort of pull
requests, changes, or just this is just
this is just your project? Uh yeah, this
is just kind of the the project I've
been enjoying doing. So it's kind of
like I no I enjoy having no pressure to
get stuff done and you know if I break
it then I'm only affecting myself. So
it's just kind of my personal project
that if you want to go see it you can
see it.
>> Cool.
>> Uh other questions.
>> Thanks for sharing that. That was great.
Um I was curious you mentioned the uh
the everex expanding MCP server. Is it
you just have one that you're putting
all the tools in and that's your single
boundary. Is that how you've designed
it?
>> Yeah. So that's just the local MCP
server. So each time an agent runs it'll
spawn its own kind of local uh standard
IO server and that's just how I can
define like um here's you know for for
example for the like markdown file read
write I can say here here's the
directory that it's allowed to go. here
are the file types that it's allowed to
do and then when it calls to try to make
a like create a file on my file system,
the MCP server will make sure those
restrictions are put in place and that's
just kind of the locally running kind of
MCP sidecar more or less that that is
scoped down to only which MCP MCP
functions the agent is allowed to use,
but also lets me build in restrictions
as each MCP call is done. So that's not
way it's not just like cloud code with
access to everything.
>> All right. Oh, all right. One followup
>> that that's really interesting. Um and
you mentioned sidecar. I mean another
way I've seen is is to do this outside
the bounds of the context window through
you know envoy and and OPA where you can
put the boundaries so you're not
consuming context through the the
bloated MCB. Have you thought about that
or tried that? I don't know if that
would work.
>> Yeah. So right now, uh, infrastructure-
wise, this is still fairly immature. I
run a lot of these agents just on my
like personal desktop is kind of where
they're running now. I have a web server
that hosts like my external MTP servers.
Um, I'm gradually right now actually
working to move that to the like a K3
setup. So working on just setting up
containers I can actually run agents in
and then I can throw in some um like
service mesh type controls as well and
see what I can do there.
>> All right.
Thanks very much. Yeah.